good day happy Friday and welcome
everyone I'm Jack Van Horn from the
University of Virginia and I'm very
proud to welcome you to this edition of
our 2022-2023 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
differing themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences
this year's theme is data science and
the public health consequences of the
covid-19 pandemic where every Friday we
hear from leading thinkers about the
issues promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of covet 19.
these health effects include delayed
Health checkups treatments mental health
drug abuse increased obesity obesity
and the long lingering health effects
associated with the SARS covid-19 virus
indeed our 2022-2023 application cycle
is now open and we strongly encourage
Junior faculty members working in areas
such as infectious disease epidemiology
clinical medicine population Health as
well as data science machine learning AI
statistics and other relevant domains to
consider applying we believe this is an
exciting and engaging program where
characterizing the secondary health
effects of covid-19 necessitates a
unique quantitative approach but also
new multi-disciplinary collaborations
participants in the selected
biomedical data science Innovation lab
program will leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant project
development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle
Washington in June of 2023.
today I am delighted to welcome not one
but two speakers Dr Olga brosnik and
Asif rizwan from the national heart lung
and Blood Institute at the National
Institutes of Health
Dr brosnik is a data scientist who
co-leads the biodata Catalyst team
and works on synthesizing data science
activities across nl88 excuse me
nhlbi following her mission to empower
individuals in communities with data and
knowledge and tools is a process of
creating their health she
brings together a broad spectrum of
disciplines from computer science to
transformative leadership and
trustworthy sustainable engagement
originally a computational physicist
Olga facilitated the adoption of
innovative approaches in biomedical
Computing and informatics collaborative
Technologies data and knowledge
integration modeling and visualization
when there's a lot of variety of
inter-agency initiatives and open
science and Innovation Asif is a health
scientist administrator who actively
manages NIH research Awards which
include genetics proteomic metabolomic
tools and systems biology approaches
is academic and research training have
given him a unique background with a
wide diversity of scientific disciplines
including biomedical engineering
Diagnostics data science Health Equity
and Technology
he also serves as a program staff on
initiatives to support whole genome
sequencing and other omic related data
analyzes he serves as program manager
for NIH rad X Tech initiatives and a
dedicated Congressional appropriation to
speed
innovation in the development
commercialization and implementation of
Technologies for coveted testing
um in continuing with our
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme
um Olga is going to be presenting
on data the data science ecosystem of
Bio the biodata Catalyst uh Asif is
going to be discussing trustworthy
inclusive and responsible AI you'll also
discuss synthetic data for biomedical
research
and we look forward to a long
conversation with each of them um in the
last 10 minutes or so of their
presentation
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and
if you are watching on YouTube thank you
so much for joining us also our
specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical
data science Innovation lab participants
and alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions they have via the chat feature
in their Zoom sessions
I'll synthesize these questions
um and we'll help to ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that Olga and
Asif welcome we are so looking forward
to your presentation
thank you so much Jack
I'm a little bit uh so I have two
screens to manage
um thank you so much I'm totally
thrilled to be here both of my children
went through the experience of the
University of Virginia one in graduate
school one in undergraduate as an
undergraduate and uh I'm totally
thrilled to be here and give back to the
community so today I will be talking
about nhlpi biodata Catalyst how we are
prioritizing diversity and my first
question to you is why is diversity even
important
I really am looking forward to your
answers because as innovators in this
biomedical Innovation lab you have ideas
that we at NIH may never have thought
about I've been not part of many
Innovation labs in my life and I know
that ideas could be amazing ideas coming
from the slabs let me tell you just a
few words about NIH and nhlbi
NIH which stands for the National
Institutes of Health an age mission is
to seek fundamental knowledge about the
nature and behavior of living system and
the application of that knowledge to
enhance health plans on life and reduce
illness and disability
NIH consists of 27 different institutes
that focus on different aspects of our
health life stages like we have
Institute of Aging child health we have
Institute of cancer National Cancer
Institute as if I represent National
heart land and Blood Institute
so
mhobi preservation for data science and
it includes leveraging emerging
opportunities in data science to open
New Frontiers in hlbs research here is a
little trick we love acronyms in the
federal government so hlbs stands for
heart lung blood and sleep research that
nhlbis focused on
so visual for data science includes new
technologies from omics platform to high
throughput screening and this potential
of vast amount of data to provide new
insight into preemption and precise
treatment of heartworm Platinum Sleep
disorders
could be optimally assessed and
incorporated into clinical care and Via
seen how it is happening and trying to
help it
we
um focus on Innovative approaches in
integration analysis and interpretation
of data from multiple sources
and enable effective use of data to
understand biological social and
behavioral determinants Association
which was hlbs health and diseases and
to improve patients outcomes
so my question to you again
I will really really appreciate your
answer answers if you want to make the
best use of data that we have right now
haven't we have enormous about the
amount of data on different aspects of
our health our life our behaviors what
would you do
what would be your Solutions
so NHL Beyond some years ago created an
hlbi biodata catalyst
as one solution to this problem with a
problem
it is the cloud-based ecosystem
providing tools applications and
workflows in secure workspaces
I want to say that that uh by data
Catalyst Consortium has a statement of
conduct
which says that it is dedicated to
providing higher estimates free
experience for everyone which means
inclusion of everyone
of different genders gender identities
age disability physical appearance and
so on inclusion and
diversity come very close together
so the explosion of clinical and
research date in recent years has led to
a need for cloud storage and Analysis
it's obvious that you cannot download
petabytes of data on your laptop and
then crunch the numbers there
so that's why
that's why we
established a cloud platform for devs
so the mission of biodata catalyst is to
develop and integrate Advanced cyber
infrastructure Leading Edge tools and
fair data to support the nhlbi research
community and the vision is to be a
Community Driven ecosystem implementing
data science solution to democratize
data in computational access to Advanced
hlbs so times
as you can see people and Technology are
combined in this ecosystem and that
makes it powerful
so one more acronyms that I used on the
previous screen uh is square data
principles I'm sure most of you know
about them but I thought it would be it
would be fair to explain what prayer
means Fair principles include findable
accessible interoperable and reusable
data if you cannot find the data set
it's very little use to you and if you
cannot access the same so and if you
cannot uh interoperate couple of
different platforms or tools to work
with the data that's obviously true and
we want to make very reusable because
it's a very valuable asset especially
data coming from clinical trials that
sometimes cost millions of dollars
so biodata Catalyst ecosystem consists
of uh people
they bring in different data in this
case uh that shows on the picture
genomics data clinical data Imaging data
and then in the biodata Catalyst you can
uh process this data store you can
reprocess
here I want to emphasize that workflows
are very important for
reproducibility of science it is a big
challenge in science to make it
reproducible
so when we work with data it seems very
simple but even in the data world it's
not so because different people follow
different uh different workflows and
different processes
so a little bit closer look at the same
uh you can search data you can create
new cohorts for your studies
combining multiple studies you can reuse
your workflow let's say and explaining I
I know maybe you know this but workflow
is a set of steps first you cleanse the
data then you combine it with something
then you uh process it with some
specific tool and then you want to
remember how you did it because the next
person who comes in may not know what
you did so say the workflows actually
enables reproducible science which is a
big advantage to this system
and um I will talk about other aspects
later but basically you can bring all
all your own tools and Publications and
work in a secure environment and apply
different tools
and other applications we also host uh
data in by data catalyst
So currently about that data Catalyst or
we call it VGC as we love acronyms
um it caused several controlled and open
data sets and my today example since I
don't have that much time to talk about
different examples I picked the
transformic for prescription for
precision medicine uh example to talk
about diverse data
um but there are other data sets and
different studies and also
um users of PDC can bring their own data
which gives you flexibility and you can
analyze co-analyzer with data hosted in
BGC and so on of course we have data use
agreements data use limitations and so
on different RB policies and guidelines
we definitely have to comply with them
so let's talk about Transformers for
precision medicine
Precision medicine is a program at NIH a
little bit more few words about NIH
basically what we do we have small
comparatively small intramural program
where people do signs at NIH but
majority of our function goes to
extramural researchers is
um and as I understood uh your
Innovation lab is funded by one of the
NIH Institute nigms natural National
Institute for General Medical Sciences
so the top map program
um the part of the sponsored by an hlbi
provides
um aims to provide disease treatments
tailored to an individual's unique juice
and environments
.map integrates whole genome sequencing
and other owners such as metabolomics
epigenomics protein RNA expression
patterns with
um database molecular behavioral Imaging
environmental and clinical data
um just a glimpse into top map data uh
these are on the left you see a whole
genome sequencing wgs stands for home
genome sequencing and different omnics
are represented in the middle and the
number of publication Publications
definitely keeps growing since uh the
beginning of top map
it has a different phenotypic data so
phenotype focus on this on this pie
chart so shows that there are data set
focused on the data is focused on blood
diseases heart diseases lung diseases
this is dogmat ancestry and ethnicity
uh we usually have a problem that
um our data sets are mostly biased
because a majority of people have
European ancestry as you can see it is
the case with top math as well however
the African ancestry takes a large piece
of this pie and so does Hispanic and
Latina population and Asian ancestry is
represented as well
so even though there is bias but there
is definitely a good good uh well
represented diversity
this is a different uh representation of
basically the same uh the same point
that we have a number of diverse
participants
um light blue represents Europeans
red represents African and uh just like
green is Hispanic Asian is in purple and
there are also others that didn't
identify or were a mixture of different
um phrases
so just to highlight several examples
from what has been achieved uh with top
map data
I want to say that for example the
asthma region was identified in
Europeans and then uh ryokozo s p was
discovered only in African Americans
which emphasizes how important it is to
know the difference between different
ancestors
also it turned out that normal lung
function reference is racial specific
this uh publication identified a causal
variance that showed that ancestry
status almost entirely accounted for the
difference in white blood counts between
African Americans and European Americans
and also genetic mutation
implementations used for diagnosis or
hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy discovered in Europeans
post false positive diagnostic results
in African Americans
so we really need diversity to make sure
that everybody everybody receives
receives good care and positive outcomes
from our treatments
so I'm coming back to the BDC ecosystem
um
obviously to provide needs of top map
researchers uh we first
focused on different types of genome
tools and so the key Tools in BDC
ecosystem include genome-wide
Association strategy genetic variant
colon structural variant colon
annotation Explorer topmath imputation
server and AI machine libraries
I wanted to give just one example
um recently had presentation from the
BDC fellows and this this example just
kind of highlighted the importance of
BDC
Jasmine albani studied malaria in Ghana
population
according to what she said uh BDC was an
incredible platform
she got her pipeline functional
uh very quickly and was able to ask
access the data quickly it would
probably take months on a local machine
so bar data Catalyst has several very
interesting features first of all it
enables team collaboration because it is
at the foundation of BGC
it allows users to bring data tools and
workflows to the data
it provides hundreds of optimized Plug
and Play tools to so researcher can
focus on their science and not
technology you really want to answer
scientific questions and not to figure
out how to put two different tools
together
it allows you to get more done in less
time it's faster computer in the cloud
it supports reproducible workflows
provides support tutorials and
documentation to help users navigate the
system it also provides 500 in Cloud
credits to new users of the system
who works on hard lung blood and sleep
research
and it continues to develop according to
user Community needs
one program that I wanted to highlight
here which might be of interest to you
it is a BGC follow program
the benefit for researcher is that it
offers early career researchers funds
and for mobile and Innovative research
for biodata Catalyst it is also
magnification because it improves the
ecosystem you and which is used
fellow feedback we'll learn how to do
business better how to provide better
environment for the scientists
it also provides engagement with
Consortium members other fellows and
broader community
is the program
provides cost for salary travel training
publication and Conference fees to a
maximum of currently 69 k
if you would like more information here
is a website that you could check
we are very focused again speaking about
people's side of digital signs I want to
mention that we are very focused on
training collaborations and being
mindful about these collaborations
uh the summer Institute uh at the
University of Washington
um
introduced
introduced
um geneticists to Modern methods of
statistical analysis and statisticians
to the challenges posed by some Modern
genetic data
um our current
um we are now establishing
collaborations with Atlanta University
Center data science initiative and
Howard University which is our local
historically black University or College
if you are interested in exploring and
learning more about biodata Catalyst you
can check out Community hours community
hours even though it says hours you
don't have to spend hours there you can
pick a topic of your interest and watch
um YouTube video about specific
interests of viewers for example on
reproducible signs
we have YouTube channel just like you do
where we have our community hours
Reflections from fellows recording from
different events and workshops and how
to's and tutorials and of course we have
newsletter that you can receive
electronically if you subscribe so all
these resources are available owned by
data Catalyst websites that I pointed to
earlier
so coming back to my question about
diversity I really am looking forward to
see your
um answers to this question but for me
it comes to the following
we live in this amazing country called
United States of America
where population is diverse in so many
different ways
we have racial diversity ethnic
diversity we have diversity in education
um religions
YouTube we have diversity among
different aspects and we want to provide
everyone with equal Health opportunity
we want to provide the basis for Health
Equity
so diversity is very important in our
data sets and in our everyday life
and I am like welcoming your thoughts
about how we come
even better to our diversity work
so biodata Catalyst prioritizes
diversity in data sets throughout
Consortium collaboration and in asking
powerful scientific questions
this is the end of my talk and I want to
express my gratitude to nhlbi leadership
to the BDC team
my nhlbi colleagues and all of you for
attention this
um this event
thank you very much this is my contact
information if you want to send email
I'll follow them up with questions I
would be happy to answer thank you
thank you Olga I think we just kick it
off with Asif from now thank you oh okay
thank you very much
thank you Olga thank you Jack let me
share my slides
right
all right the title of my first talk is
just what the inclusive and responsible
AI for biomedical research I'm massive
is one I'm a program director at nhfbi
in the blood division
Ai and machine learning have made
positive impact
in machine learning algorithms
develops for disease Diagnostics
prognosis drug Discovery protein
structure prediction Imaging
patient interaction healthcare
administration and for many other
reasons AI can learn from from
from the features in the data Ai and
machine learning can help streamline
clinical decision for example
Technologies such as Alpha phone can
predict protein structures with high
precision
it can save a lot of time and resources
for research
machine learning algorithms are widely
used in heart disease cancer detection
COPD asthma management sickle cell
anemia pain research and for many other
research at NIH and across many other
federal agencies
machine learning and AI can keep us more
precise understanding of basic science
how to design new biomaterials patient
management and overall is helping health
research and Healthcare
given um given the power of AI and ml it
is clear that the scientists have the
desire to engage with machine learning
research for instance there are close to
1500 NIH funded new projects in machine
learning and AI category with a total of
more than like 800 million dollar in
funding during the fiscal year 2020 and
2021 you can see the spending amount by
27 IC here ICN centers here such as NCI
cancer aging heart lung blood and sleep
and other ICS
however
although there is a rapid growth and
Adoption of machine learning the lack of
insights how exactly the machine
Learning Works has delayed the full
scientific understanding and also has
led to distrust and hesitation in using
machine learning algorithm
some of the challenges are lack of
transparency limited data lack of
explainability and interpretability lack
of inclusiveness security concern and
accountability concern
many agencies and institutes have
started creating guidelines to emphasize
the role of trustworthy AI
machine learning subject matter experts
have raised this trust for the topic at
conferences Acro conferences and
workshops across NIH FDA Food and Drug
Administration National Institute of
Standards a technology anist and at many
other places
machine learning and AI are by means no
by no means perfect there are many
concerns that must be addressed so to
build and to maintain public trust in Ai
and machine learning we need to create
and adopt the principle of trustworthy
AI
U.S Department of Health and Human
Service has created a trustworthy AI
playable they have identified six key
components
number one fair and impartial
number two transparent and explainable
number three responsible and accountable
number four safe and secure number five
privacy and the last one robust and
reliable
so I will briefly talk on all of this
component on my next slides
we are an impartial AI models must make
predictions that do not introduce biases
into the model
impartiality must be considered
throughout the entire model developments
which includes data collection model
model design testing and considering
social determinants of Health as a
factor for the machine learning model
machine learning outcome must be
accurate with all demographics for all
race religion gender
a 2022 uh study a recent study uh uh
tested several different Ai and machine
learning models that can identify liver
disease through blood test that study
found that the machine learning model
missed 44 percent liver disease cases
for a woman
however the model only missed 23 percent
cases for men this is an example of
inconsistency in Modern Performance
Based on gender
bias is present in the data can
propagate ratio and social preferences
in the machine learning model
a study found that pulse oximeters made
mistakes when used on Asian Black and
Hispanic population
machine learning algorithm that were
created by this pulse of signature data
might make wrong prediction
many genomic studies were done in the
European population as always has
mentioned in her in the last talk
so this uh result may have limited
utility across population therefore we
must establish fair and impartial data
sources and algorithms
transparency and explainable
everyone involved with the research with
the data with the machine learning
research research should be properly
informed about how their data is being
used
how the AI system makes it makes its
decision transparency is essential for
Regulatory Agencies such as FDA to
review and to approve the models
recently research investigated the
association between uh surgical surgical
skill marking in thermoscopic images and
Diagnostics performance of a deep
learning neural network they found that
machine learning model classified images
with surgical skin marker so this is a
mole if there is surgical skin marker
around the mole uh the machine learning
model uh like made mistakes they did not
pay uh attention to the right features
so so investigator could consider
developing an explainability method
overall uh explainability and
transparency have many potential
application in understanding the actual
model and in understanding the biases
responsibility accountability so machine
learning policies should Define who is
responsible for all aspects of AI and
machine learning
this also includes if a machine learning
algorithm leads to a bad outcome who is
at fault the researcher who created the
technique
the business implementing the research
the doctor watching over the algorithm
the hospital is in the algorithm is
anyone at fault what what do you think
this feel free to write your comments in
the chat
researchers should be transparent with
their machine learning model data
sources methods results and
implementation of the model
this also includes uh
like this also includes like you know
how how do you communicate mistakes
mistakes if
a critical device
decision there should be a clear roles
and responsibilities in place
to respond to the problem
and how we can prevent this from
happening
Safety and Security
machine learning models can become
useless if proper security measures are
not taken
one study found that a machine learning
model trained on data sets injected with
even 0.1 percent noise could lead to a
wrong outcome
when we consider like you know how much
effort and resources it takes to collect
the data for this model
then we we must understand that like we
must make sure that AI systems are safe
and secure
this should be a top priority to ensure
trustworthy machine learning
privacy
are are patient providing the data being
adequately informed and giving consent
does the data contain pii Phi or other
sensitive data has that has the data
been de-identified or encrypted
the Privacy rights of all individuals
and entities and groups should be
preserved and maintained
data Collective
from individuals should not be used for
anything more than what it was
authorized for this has been a major
cause of cause for concern in machine
learning research Studies have shown
that
even data that has been de-identified
there are some technique to re-identify
that data so this is a big risk for
privacy
robust robustness and reliability AI
system should have the ability to learn
from humans and other systems and
produce accurate and reliable outputs
consistent with the original design
the model must work in the real world
it's it must produce accurate and
reliable outputs if a researcher is not
careful a good AI machine learning model
that works in a test population that
works in in a lab might be inaccurate
when using real people data with a
variety of symptoms and issues
is the training that accurate represents
is the sharing data uh the real
representative of the real world
settings and is the training data free
of noise and outliers these are the some
of the key questions that we should all
consider are the models output sensitive
to small variation in the inputs how do
you how do you manage new versions of AI
Solutions
NIH and many other agencies have started
pushing a lot of attention to this
challenge of trustworthy or AI
energy aim ahead program was created to
Advance Health Equity and diversity
programs like aim ahead will increase
the representation of underrepresented
communities by building partnership
NIH bridge to AI
is is another program that aims to
develop ethically Source deficits for AI
projects there are many other activities
across NIH such as metric Medical
Imaging and data Resource Center in 3C
National covet cohort collaborative and
all the mentioned lhsbi Biore Catalyst a
cloud ecosystem
so all these programs try to address
some aspects of trustworthy AI
they all want to address the harmful
potential biases in the data and in the
models uh so there is there is also a
lot of potential room to continue
working towards the trust for the AI
initiatives across uh all the federal
agencies
this summer uh one of our intern Eric
Rosie who was a
uh odss
coding It Forward summer fellow that is
also a good program for any any grad any
students who are interested to work in
the NIH so please check that out in the
in the odss and coding It Forward
website
so Eric analyzed uh publicly available
image data to find NIH projects with a
focus on the trustworthy AI principle
he conducted a keyword analysis as shown
in the in table one these are the
keywords that's the that's the category
accountable impartial privacy reliable
security secure and transparent
um he counted the number of projects in
interest in each of these trust or the
category as shown in table two
overall he found that only 11 percent of
machine learning projects between 2019
and 2021 mentioned trustworthy AI
keywords so it shows that there are
rooms for growth
in this talk uh we tried to Define
certain principles as modeled by uh
Health and Human Service guidelines we
also showed relevant examples where
these principles could be addressed as
you can see from the figure
the input from all stakeholders
uh like you know uh patients caregivers
researchers clinicians communities uh
they all can provide feedback on
existing and emerging machine learning
tools to identify the gaps in the
trustworthy principle
most importantly the adoption of these
principles must be widespread researcher
from all different backgrounds companies
government organization clinicians
patients we must all adopt and advocate
for trustworthy AI principles to make
sure that AI systems are truly helping
individuals
trustworthy inclusive responsible AI
will benefit all individuals
it will prevent both intentional and
unintentional harms and solve our
mission in enhancing health
so I would like to acknowledge our
initial bi leadership uh
initial be a data science Coordinating
Committee odss leadership
and also most of the most of the uh
items that I presented today were
prepared by Eric Rossi who as I
mentioned he was a Civic digital fellow
so please check that out this is that is
a good opportunity for students to work
in an age for 10 weeks in the summer
all right uh I will uh since we don't
have much time I'll jump into my next
talk
um synthetic Health Data for biomedical
research
what is synthetic data synthetic Health
Data is an inexpensive alternative to
real-wall data
Centric data maintains the statistical
property of the original data
it is normally free of restriction that
comes with Phi projected health
information and pii personally
identifiable information
synthetic data can meet the principle of
fair
findability accessibility
interoperability and reusability and
elsi ethical legal and social
implication uh I've also mentioned that
uh in her talk on the biological
catalyst so simply there's a uh can meet
those principles
synthetic data can be structured or
unstructured they can be generated from
existing real-wall data or can be new
there are many techniques to develop
synthetic data
generative adversarial networks is one
of the best known deep learning based
model to General synthetic data
why we need synthetic data
we have seen many breakthrough in
data-driven technology in health
research
this type of Technology depends on large
amounts of Quality Health Data
however to access and to use Health Data
are often challenging
sometimes we need many actually not
sometimes all the time we need many
different types of regulatory approval
to access the data
many Health Data can have a limited
sharing concerns especially if the data
comes from vulnerable population
a lot of Health Data have location
information
addresses Phi pii sometimes it is
difficult to fully de-identify this type
of Health Data
sometimes actual data can be very small
actual data may not be representative of
the scope and the longitude or not over
the time like you know you're getting
data from multiple years
longitudinal aspects of the population
sensory data can be used uh to create a
bigger Health data sets which can be
then which can then be used to develop
machine learning models and tools
data for training and research sometimes
it is challenging for training mpis from
a especially from a limited resource
settings where they may lack the support
and the resources for use for using
actual Health Data synthetic data can
help in this situation as well
right so these are uh some of the
selected publication on synthetic Health
Data the use of synthetic data have
increased a lot recently it is estimated
that by 2030 most of the data used in
machine learning will be since
artificially generated
some of the recent Publications have
shown the use of techniques of synthetic
health and biomedical data
synthetic patient data Centric data in
machine learning for medicine and
Healthcare synthetic genomic data
publication has shown that synthetic
Health data sets are not significantly
different from original data in terms of
feature distribution feature
dependencies and sensitivity
overall the risk of generating and using
synthetic data is low
some of the Health and Human Service
supported activities
there are there are actually several
ongoing research on synthetic Health
Data NIH ncats National Center for
advancing translational science they
have a centralized secure data ecosystem
to study covet 19. this is known as n3c
National covet code collaborative m3c
collects data from the electronics
health records and this data ecosystem
has a synthetic data that were generated
from the actual patient data citizen
scientists can access this synthetic
Health Data
onc office of national coordinator for
health information technology onc
initiated a synthetic Health Data
generation projects in 2019 with a
support from Pico TF patient-centered
outcome research trust fund this project
wanted to produce they produced a lot of
high quality synthetic Health Data by
Cynthia data generator they generated
several synthetic data module modules
such as sepsis leukemia opioids use
pediatric population
yeah you can you can go to their website
and cash website and once your website
for more up-to-date information and the
status of these projects
there have been a steady increase in the
number of application with synthetic
data at NIH
uh we found that the total number of
applications that were that came to an
edge and total number of applications
that were funded both of these numbers
are going up over the years quality of
application have increased has increased
as well
so the timing appears to be right for
research for synthetic data in
biomedical research
here are some examples of research
Awards funded by initial bi these are
all publicly available information at
nihreporter.gov website so please go to
their website if you are if you are
interested to know more to know more
about all of this synthetic data that is
funding in one application uh Pi is
developing a privacy uh privacy uh
preserving synthetic data sets for
clinical decision
another application is using synthetic
data to understand the impact of uh
physician learning on the safety of
cardiovascular devices
another Pi is using a synthetic
segmentation to develop a models of
ecocardiographic image
in conclusion uh this is my last slide
uh synthetic can maximize access while
protecting the data privacy and sharing
restriction
same thing that I can reduce uh cost it
can eliminate many legal restrictions of
data sharing
synthetic data can
um uh like you know improve teaching and
training opportunities for Next
Generation biomedical scientists
sensory data can be used for testing
theories and algorithm they can also
provide big data for genetics and
genome-wide Association study they can
allow creation of population specific
test data set especially specifically
for vulnerable population or diverse
population it can reduce bias and will
allow training and Ai and machine
learning models for targeted
intervention as well
so I would like to acknowledge initial
bi leadership
uh initial bi data science Coordination
Committee their leadership and also I
would like to acknowledge
he is also a program director at Citrus
nhpi and he is working heavily on
scientific data at the initial bi
all right I will stop sharing my slides
now and I can take any questions great
Asif and Olga thank you so much to the
both of you for providing these
wonderful overviews of what's going on
at uh nhlbi and these various programs
um going on with um Ai and ml
applications
um just uh some great resources in there
thank you so much for sharing all those
one of the things which I learned Olga
from your presentation which I just
didn't fully appreciate was that uh
nhlbi actually has a silent S at the end
with uh sleep research I did not know
that and uh so that may be very
interesting for people who are
interested in uh like doing sleep
research
um that maybe na nhlbi is the place to
look for that
yes we have a sleep center right that's
fantastic well one of the things which
is kind of interesting about the um the
Catalyst ecosystem is you mentioned um
harmonization which I think is like one
of the critical elements of this where
we have such a diversity of data
um you want to be able to make them play
well with each other and make them
interoperable you know which is the I
and the fair principles and I'm curious
about the role of Standards or at least
best practices from the point of view of
the Catalyst or your point of view or
from the nih's point of view about why
that might be important
of course it is important of course it
is very important because if we all
follow different standards and uh the
joke was from my early years uh what is
good about standards there are so many
to choose from but if
but if we all follow different standards
um like you take an example not from the
data world but from the real when you go
and travel to different countries you
have to bring this device that plugs
into different electric Outlets to make
your
um to make your whatever electric
devices you brought with your work as
the same with data of course we follow
different standards for different
reasons because people cannot
also the Anthology word was uh used to
be only singular now it's plural and we
all use anthologies because Anthology is
supposed to be a concept A specification
of conceptualization but as we know we
cannot agree on religions we all follow
different paths in life and system on
beliefs of beliefs but uh there should
be something common in uh in all this so
we can communicate to each other
now when we talk about the data
standards the same is true here when we
bring
um different data from different
standards and different ontology we have
to harmonize them we have to make sure
we have this uh device that plugs into
the our data system that transforms the
data that we collected according to one
standard into a different standard or
different data model
so um
uh there are a lot of efforts on
standardizing
um many different data but at the same
time we do acknowledge that people use
different standards and when we come
together we have to do a lot of uh not a
lot but hopefully not so many
transformations to make some point
together which is called harmonization
of data as you mentioned
specific policies but I can definitely
send you everybody who is interested to
visit odss website data science
audiences is our office of data science
strategy at NIH
um that has all the policy guidance on
standards and
um different aspects different other
aspects of data science that's wonderful
Olga and this kind of the the notion of
harmonization kind of leads me to a
question for Asif concerning you
mentioned trustworthiness in Ai and ml
applications and I think you know the
how the data are harmonized kind of
helps to support the trustworthy nature
of data and the algorithms that one
would want to apply on it and it brings
me to kind of this notion if you had the
figure that kind of showed a a series of
things about uh you know about
robustness and privacy and
accountability and whatnot not it
occurred to me that a lot there's a huge
balancing act that has to go on to make
all of that work so for example you
could have something that's really a
robust algorithm but it's just not
explainable so you could repeatably you
know get the same answer all the time
but you have no idea why
um in contrast you may have fairness of
the the data types that are being uh
included and very they could be very
diverse
but on the other hand you have to
balance people's privacy and it has to
be accountable there needs to be
accountability I'm curious about how
someone can help to keep that Balancing
Act you know keep all the plates
spinning if it were
so so Jack like you know um at this
moment everyone has a
different definition of trustworthiness
uh like uh explainability fairness
reliability privacy safety
responsibility so uh we hope people will
keep this in mind when they design their
research imagine all the researchers are
hypothesis driven right so you design an
experiment you you get the data and you
analyze the data so if if we can at
least keep all this trustworthy
principle in mind you know then uh I I
strongly believe uh it will improve the
trustworthy AI this data will be fed
into the model right so
uh overall I think uh yeah like uh we
have to keep all these things in mind
and uh it will take some times like we
have been talking about cluster di for
the last several years uh but uh uh it
is difficult it's difficult to uh
Implement all these principles
yeah that's the thing is that it seems
like there's sustainability and you know
experiment is not easy and some people
don't like it they don't want to hear
about it especially if they're hardcore
data scientists uh which I understand
like you know sometimes it is not
possible it cannot explain each of the
layer but uh but some sort of
explainability will be useful that is
what I'm trying to say so if you one
thing that's kind of wondering about is
is this a potential role for some of the
synthetic data that you mentioned as Eve
could it help to uh bolster some of the
you know explainability robustness
fairness privacy you know obviously it
there's no privacy to necessarily be
worried about but can this help us to
make sure that we can do that Balancing
Act it can help us to help Define
standards and help kind of build this
little feedback loop um to make sure
that people
um are comfortable with what's Ai and ml
have to offer us absolutely absolutely
yeah that is one of the big use of that
will be one of the big use of synthetic
data people can like you know develop
new model they can twist the data they
will have access to the data the problem
with the Health Data the biggest problem
is that you need to have all this type
of regulatory approval IRB approval and
some of the data we just cannot share
like so API developer model based on the
data we don't know what the data where
you know it's sometimes difficult for
others to verify the model so since we
get a differently can help us to spread
the data share the data use hackathon
challenge price like you know
competition like so it will be much
easier definitely there's a big use of
sensitive data I think we've heard from
some of the other NIH um folks that we
have had join us about various uh
challenges and hackathon type things and
uh there's some interesting challenges
that actually you can win and win prize
money I'm curious if there are any that
you might uh point us to before we leave
today
or you could share them with with me and
I can make sure that they get to our
audience members sure I I can we can
share that with you that'd be fantastic
because one of the things which I always
enjoy about talking with folks from the
NIH is that they provide us with these
great big picture uh programs and ideas
and kind of where the NIH is going and
inside of all of that if you unpack it
there's all these little nuggets of
amazing opportunities and I want to make
sure that uh our readers and our future
biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants have full access to those
so they can take advantage of them
um so please yeah send me anything that
I might need to know with that uh Olga
and Asif thank you so much for sharing
uh these great programs and and these uh
things that are happening at the level
of the NIH in terms of the national
heart lung and blood and Sleep Institute
and we are super excited to uh kind of
follow up on some of these and uh with
that said thank you again and everyone
have a wonderful weekend
thank you Jack it's been a privilege to